i want to do a quick argument or proof
as to why the diagonals of a rhombus are
perpendicular so remember a rhombus is
just a parallelogram
where all four sides are equal in fact
if all four sides are equal it has to be
a parallelogram and just to make things
clear
some rhombuses are squares but not all
of them because you could have a rhombus
like this that comes in where the angles
aren't 90 degrees but all squares are
rhombuses because all squares they have
90 degree angles here that's not what
makes them a rhombus but all of the
sides are equal so all squares are
rhombuses but not all rhombuses are
squares now with that said let's think
about the diagonals of a rhombus and
think about that a little bit clearer
i'm going to draw the die i'm going to
draw the rhombus really is kind of i'm
going to rotate a little bit so it looks
a little bit like a diamond shape
so but notice i'm not really changing
any of the properties of the rhombus i'm
just drawing it i'm just changing its
orientation a little bit
i'm just changing its orientation so a
rhombus by definition the four sides are
going to be equal now let me draw one of
its diagonals and the way i drew it
right here is kind of a diamond
one of its diagonals will be right along
the horizontal right like that now this
triangle on the top and the triangle on
the bottom both share this side so that
side is obviously is going to be the
same length for both of these triangles
and then the other two sides of the
triangles are also the same thing
they're sides of the actual rhombus so
all three sides of this top triangle and
this bottom triangle are the same so
this top triangle and this bottom
triangle are congruent they are
congruent triangles if you go back to
your your ninth grade geometry you'd use
the side side side theorem to prove that
three sides are the are congruent then
the triangles themselves are congruent
but that also means that all the angles
in the triangle are congruent so the
angle that is opposite this side the
shared side right over here over here
will be congruent to the same the
corresponding angle in the other
triangle the side the angle opposite
this side so it would be the same thing
as that
now both of these triangles are also
isosceles triangles so their base angles
are going to be the same so that's one
base angle that's the other base angle
right this is an upside down isosceles
triangle this is a right side up one and
so if this if these two are the same and
these are also going to be the same
they're going to be the same to each
other because this is an isosceles
triangle and they're also going to be
the same as these other two characters
down here because these are congruent
triangles now
if we take an altitude and actually you
know i didn't actually even have to talk
about that since actually i don't think
that'll be relevant when we actually
want to prove what we want to prove if
we take an altitude from each of these
vertices
down to this side right over here so an
altitude by definition and altitude by
definition is going to be perpendicular
down here now an isosceles triangle is
perfectly symmetrical if you drop an
altitude from the i guess you can call
it the top or the unique angle or the
unique vertex in an isosceles triangle
you will split it into two symmetric
right triangles two right triangles that
are essentially the mirror images each
of each other you will also bisect you
will also
you will also bisect the opposite side
this altitude is in fact a median of the
triangle now we can do it on the other
side
the same exact thing is going to happen
we are bisecting this side over here
this is a right angle and so essentially
the combination of these two altitudes
is really just a diagonal of this
rhombus and it's at a right angle to the
other diagonal of the rhombus and it
bisects that other diagonal of the
rhombus and we can make the exact same
argument over here you could think of a
isosceles triangle you could think of an
isosceles triangle over here
this is an altitude of it it splits it
into two symmetric right triangles it
bisects the opposite side it's
essentially a median of that triangle
any isosceles triangle any isosceles
triangle if that side is equal to that
side if you drop an altitude
these two triangles are going to be
symmetric and you will have bisected you
will have bisected the opposite side so
by the same argument that side's equal
to that side so the two diagonals of any
rhombus of two of any rhombus are
perpendicular to each other and they
bisect each other
and they bisect each other anyway
hopefully you found that useful